[Applause]
hold person sound I'll take a second hi
hello hi my name is Officer Westman stop
is being recorded the reason you're
being stopped was a few things so when
you turned onto California Street you
didn't use your turn signal then you
almost hit a curb then you made a left
hand turn here onto a street again not
using your turn
signal okay I'm sorry were you just
distracted by something I just I'm I'm
sorry I usually okay we're here
frequently so sorry I um I see you have
blood coming down your
hand what's going on with
that oh that's a personal reason yeah
are you okay I'm fine right did you cut
yourself yep how long
ago I don't really think that's any of
your business I'm sorry all right I'm
just concerned no that's fine no I'm
just here to
okay do you have your driver's license
with you I do
wait I don't have my wallet with me
actually okay I'm sorry do you have your
registration and insurance for the car
is will that One
Direction
hello
yep what do you what do you
mean I need you to focus on the task at
hand your phone call is not the priority
I got to go I'm
sorry what's up I need your registration
insurance for the
[Applause]
vehicle how old are you 19 okay I think
okay I think this is
my let me make sure okay yeah this is my
recent insurance I got a new car last
year okay this is here and I think this
is
my uh it talks about warranties and all
sorts of things is this not the so no
that one is not this one's your
registration okay you were looking for
an insurance car insurance okay I think
that's on
my app okay merid can you come talk to
me outside the car
please because I'm instructing you to
step out of your vehicle is there a
reason why it's a lawful order you have
to step out of your vehicle now' is
there a reason is it a lawful order yes
ma'am step out of your
vehicle can you come back
here so I'm
concerned how you doing this is where I
live okay
cool yeah sounds
good so I'm kind of concerned about how
much alcohol you've had to drink tonight
plus your driving would you be willing
to do some voluntary field to tests is
that a voluntary thing correct they're
voluntary so if I say no what is that
then I have to make my decision based on
the observations to this
point which is like based on what you're
poor
driving driving on what me not cutting
my blinker not using your blinker nearly
striking the curb when you pulled into
this parking lot instead of just coming
to a stop we went through all of these
cars and then came back here well this
is where I was pulling into so okay you
just have to say yes or no you want to
do the test what what do I do if I say
no do if I say no then I have to make my
decision based on the observations I've
seen at this point which is what I've
just can you be honest with me if I say
no like what happens beyond that it if I
believe that I'm like just genuinely
like scared of like what's going on here
like I've I I've seen too many videos
and I'm scared that I don't like trust
you guys so like what's going on beh
beyond that I'm here so I think you're
in
toxicated okay okay so at this time you
are under arrest place your hands behind
your back wait no no don't tense up
don't tense up relax relax what the she
has Dred blood on your hand get anything
please no one will walk up to this
otherwise they will be
detained what do you mean I'm under Rel
rela what do you mean I didn't do
anything I didn't do anything I didn't
DOI what do you mean I didn't do
anything you the right my car you have
the right to remain silent anything you
say get him get my car at least the
right at this time to talk to an
attorney and have him present with you
while you're being question if you
cannot afford to hire an attorney when V
represent without cost if you so desire
tell him to get my car at least Joey you
can decide at any time he's in there
tell him to get my car to make any Stat
or today is the 15th of September 2023
it is 0128 hours I don't
have anything she said it was a personal
reason she didn't want to talk to me
about it okay okay we're going to walk
to the rear of my patrol
[Applause]
car do you have anything on you that can
stick or stab me like a pocket knife
needles something of that
sort nope okay do you have pockets on
your skirt no or these shorts
no okay can I at least have my phone
relax please please relax fighting this
is not going to change anything I need
you to relax
okay not at the moment I'll come talk to
you in a second have a
seat what are you you haven't even what
are you would you like Medics to come
look at your wrist no okay can you just
why are you arresting me you are under
arrest for operating a vehicle while
under the influence of alcohol to the
point that it's impaired your drink
you want me to get your phone for
you like I can use it um well you can
have it with you he's probably going to
take you to the the police station you
probably want to have it why am I okay
can I ask you guys have not have any
like
official for yes why are you guys ring
me like may ask like you guys have no
official like information of why
oh well he has to go by his observation
so what he saw what he is what oh I
don't I'm not me not turning my fucking
blinker on which is what half the people
in pman do no I'm not going to argue you
want your phone
though yes
[Music]
ask ask Nathan
okay appreciate you guys not walking up
sorry sir uh what questions can I answer
I can't answer all of them I'm her
boyfriend yep can I can I just ask
what's happening she is under arrest for
du she's highly intoxicated I told her
not dve and she driv I told her I would
walk there and I got a call and she was
talking on her way what are the next
steps for us to go she'll be with me for
about the next six hours as as her
boyfriend what can I do nothing really
we're going to make sure that her phone
goes with her so when she's released
should I contact their parents should I
should I I
wouldn't that that' be her just that'll
be her Choice what about a we're just
going to lock it up here just just leave
it here just leave it here yep is it on
right now yeah don't worry about we'll
take you turn it off please yes we're
going to lock it all right all right
appreciate you guys thank you all right
she'll give you a call when she has an
opportunity can I can I tell you
something and and not I'm recording OB I
know if you're recording whatever but
not make it obvious to her
sure would just really appreciate this
night has been very rough for her and
the reason she came over here and I told
her not her I said I will walk to your
house and I don't know why she didn't
listen and I but she's just not in a
good place right now so if you'll keep
that in mind I would reallying is coming
from and all that yeah is she is she
bleeding right now she told me she was
cutting herself tonight it's uh dried so
it's not like actively bleeding please
keep we'll continue to talk to her about
it and try to get her resources and
we'll get her Medics too she needs it
yeah right now she just very much
doesn't want that so okay all right I
know it's a lot of information to
process in the moment I'm not I'm not se
but I understand but I just I just hope
I just want you guys to know that she's
not there mentally H and and she's Hest
I could tell by the way she was talking
to you guys she's drunk and not there so
yeah I appreciate it please he said he
said they're going to be about 6 hours
with find way to did you find a so so in
the morning in the morning she wanted
him to look for it in the car in the
morning should I come to the the Poli
station and pick her up um so how about
this she wants you to find her cell
phone to make sure it goes with her do
you mind looking in the car you know
what it looks like grab her cell phone
and then yes she'll be able to give you
a call you want to give you guys the
keys oh
sure you want to roll up the windows and
lock
it
okay yep thank you very much yep we'll
make sure this goes with her cool thank
you yes yes in the morning in the
morning should I should I come to the
police station and if that's what she
wants and pick her up yeah as long as
you're sober and and will will she be
able to call me in the morning to tell
me yeah when she gets released she'll
have her cell phone she'll be able to
call who and she we release at the like
in 6 hours or in the morning yes as long
as she doesn't have a prior DUI if she
had a prior DUI or warrants for arrest
then she'd have to go to jail I know she
doesn't so okay all right
yep can I get out
yep
all
right stand to the right of the door so
I can get the next door for
you we're going go up to that brown
chair in front of
you you want me sit in it stand it or
what I don't want you to stand in it but
you can
have can you take these off please can I
have my phone no why cuz that's not far
the
process okay how I don't want to be here
for the rest of the night I'm old
regardless if you provide a sample or
not you're going to be here for the
majority of the evening are you kidding
me not one
bit so whether you provide the sample or
not does not change that fact you're
under the age of 21 you've consumed a
fair amount of alcohol to the point that
you're impaired based on my observations
based on your observations right okay so
if I say no then what if I say if I say
yes then what if you say yes then we do
the two samples just as I described in
this document if you say no I mark it as
a refusal and I continue with the
paperwork and if you mark it as a
refusal then
what then it can be used in a criminal
trial why don't I just read this
document again because you have
questions about exactly what we I heard
what you said but I want to hear like a
if I say yes this if I say no that
exactly what I just asked right so if
you provide a
breath we're going to do the machine
after that you're going to go in that
holding cell for up to 6 hours if you
Mar know that you don't want to do the
breath you're going to go in that cell
for up to 6 hours same result the
difference is what the Department of
Licensing does with your driver's
license which is what I'm going to
reread this document because
tell me please I'm not allowed to
interpret this what do I have to do to
just breathe this and I don't want to be
here like is there any way I can just be
like boom whatever you take my license
away and I go please i i l just don't
want be here my plan what is as long as
you don't have any warrants for your
rest and you don't have a prior to UI
then I'm not booking you into the county
jail just please like
all right so we'll go back to the
question will you now submit to a breath
test that's fine I just wan to I just
want to go okay like what's the soonest
I can get out of here please I don't
want
to so the soonest you can get out of
here is probably about 4:00 a.m. it's 2:
a.m. right now that's 2
hours you could be here up to 6 that's
the longest you're allowed to be here I
know but who's going to pick me up at 4
A.M no your boyfriend I spoke with him
yeah no he's not going to be away that
hour he said he's waiting for your phone
call so he can come and pick you up he
said he's sober he can come pick you
up can we just get this over with please
I'm trying to do it as quickly as
possible the next section is a question
answer section some of these questions
are going to sound silly or redundant I
just have to ask them the same do you
have any physical impairments please put
your feet down I went come to your house
and put my feet on yours please put your
feet down no do you limp do I limp yes
ma'am no are you sick or injured at the
moment sure no sorry that's no two
answers okay are you under the care of a
doctor or
dentist what yes isn't everyone under
the care of of a I think they mean more
like you got a procedure like coming up
or something I don't know my mom's a
dentist I don't know I'm always under
the are you diabetic or epileptic no do
you take insulin no have you taken any
medicines or drugs in the last 24 hours
no any prescription medications
non-prescription
medications start app then have you had
any cocaine no any marijuana no any
other drugs no do you have impaired
Vision no do you wear ctive lenses no
were you wearing them at the time you
were stopped obviously not obviously not
but I got to ask questions um how many
hours of sleep did you get last
night no do you count the hours of sleep
sleep you get per night do you yeah I
got about seven and a half I I don't
know I probably fell asle at like 1 I
woke up at like 9:30 so I don't know
hours right okay sure you
think uh were you driving the vehicle
nope that's odd it was a ghost it wasn't
me huh okay anything mechanically wrong
with the vehicle no um my tire pressure
is off they say
okay all right now yes I was driving the
vehicle sorry was making a joke of
course I was okay I appreciate
that like obviously have you been in
injured or involved in any collisions
last 24
hours no have you had any alcohol to
drink since being stopped meaning me
pulling you over no what do you
mean meaning me pulling me since you've
been handcuffing me how how slick do you
think I am some people say yes OB not
some people say yes obviously not
okay where were you going before I
sucked you um you know I don't right
there where you pulled me over okay
you're heading to the parking lot yep on
a street yep
okay without looking what time do you
think it
is I don't know I don't even know what
time it was I left actually maybe
like
11:23 okay it's very specific what time
is it right now is currently 156 is it
really
damn what street were you on when I
stopped you a
street do you know which direction
you're traveling north south east west
south
okay where' you start driving
from n is that an option I can I can
write down if you want the retreat I
just don't why is that any of their
business like I said I just have to fill
out the paper um do you recall what time
you started
driving 10 minutes before 10 minutes
like before I stopped you
probably what day of the week is
it
Thursday what city slcounty are you in
now oh crazy huh main County
99163 huh
it's good A lot of people don't know the
county what's today's date 9:14
23 good thing I know cuz I go to class
every day huh have you been drinking
alcoholic beverages I don't
know question you have to see if there
no okay okay if I say no then what if I
say yes then what no then I just mark
down your answer this is not to trick
you or anything I just record your
answer okay uh what have you been
drinking n
again I don't know how to spell that
none none y yeah right right right right
you got it how much did you have to
drink I I have no
idea I thought I was SM we were drinking
at our friends after earlier and we all
walk back and then I went to get get my
boyfriend fine but okay uh what time did
you start drinking I have no idea n yeah
all right no idea it's easier to write
now um who have you been drinking
with what who have you been drinking
with who you want me to list like all
like the 20 names of people I can write
friends friends it's a little easier
yep uh where were you
drinking um
switched sorry we were at the land and
then we walked back to our house and
then we walked back to our other
friend's house so I don't really know
what you're want to say private houses
sure do you recall all the time your
last
drink no um I think
we do you believe your ability to drive
was affected by your alcohol and or drug
use
no
she have you been arrested for DIY
before
no this say 40 seconds left on it punch
in all the
information time to do your sample what
I'm going to have you do is you're going
to stand up can I just go home please no
at the moment I know but after this
please
just and if I do just let me go home I
will do my best please listen to the
instructions I'm going to put this into
the breath nozzle when I tell you you're
going to stand up you're going to take a
deep breath so your lungs can't hold any
more air then you're going to blow
steady through this tube until all the
air is gone it's going to make me used
to do
EO you do breath lasers
yep um it might be a little different
it's still thinking you can sit if you
want do it um it's going to take about
10 second sample it's probably longer
than your
to go and take your deep breath
in and blow out blow blow blow blow blow
keep going keep going keep going keep
going you're about halfway keep going
keep going keep going keep going and
stop have a seat that's going I think
for just a couple minutes we'll do it
one more time and then I can take the
handcuffs off can you please just like
after just give me a ticket and let me
go please
I all right okay have a seat
we're almost through this part no I know
I really don't want to be here please I
fully understand you don't you don't
have you ever been here in this position
no you don't I wouldn't be allowed to be
a police officer exactly you don't know
what it feels like so don't say you know
cuz you don't no I understand you don't
want to be here is what I'm saying but
to an extent you don't understand cuz
you've never been in this seat before
with your hands CU behind your
back I just want to go
home and I don't care like at this point
like whatever happens I I just want to
go home there's no point me
here just trve be cool
please what do you want we have to do
the second one and then it's done I
can't even okay take your deep breath in
you I'm sorry take your deep breath in
please we're almost done
s okay and blow
out blow blow blow blow blow keep going
keep going keep going keep going keep
going oh you unsealed your lips so the
air didn't go through it your deep
breath in
as soon as you provide the sample I can
get the Handcuff off blow out blow blow
blow blow blow blow blow blow blow blow
keep going keep going keep going keep
going keep going keep going keep going
keep going almost there keep going keep
going keep
going
okay that was my body camera that was
going Ma shoot is it fine though uh it's
going to tell me here in
second
off me like I know how to do it what do
you pleas listen to me I just said the
words I'm going to take your handcuffs
off I thought you said take your
handcuffs off like I don't do
it hold still please hold still if you
twist it I can't get them off go back
how you
want please sit
down have a seat right there sit
down I don't think you really understand
the gravity of the situation right now
the way you're behaving is
childish just want to I understand that
but you decided to drive intoxicated
tonight through the streets of pulman
where there's hundreds of people walking
around thank God you didn't hit
anyone
your result she are going to print off
in a minute after that we're going to
review it together after that you're
going to be placed in a Cell where you
will remain until you are released until
when can't tell you when it'll be within
6 hours I will get you a blanket and
you'll stay there I'll be back with you
in a couple hours can I make a call or
what no back with you what is that about
I thought that was like I can TV that's
if you're booked into jail you don't
want to be booked into jail what I can't
make one call no it's a TV thing this is
a holding fail it's not a jail okay but
what I can't get in the cell what I
can't make a call to anyone get in the
cell do it now for how
long get in the cell for how long you
can be up here for 6 hours I don't know
how many more times I could answer that
question for you you don't have any
answer for me 6 hours get in the
cell fuck you yeah I
know okay this piece of paper is your
right to a hearing because you provided
a breath sample you have the right to
have a telephonic hearing about the
potential upcoming suspension of your
license if you would like to do that you
need to send in a check for
$375 within 7 days from today to this
address here Department of Licensing if
you don't send it in they just assume
you don't want that hearing okay so that
piece of
paper you don't have to say anything I
know
okay this piece of paper is um talking
about this so it says notice of a right
to a hearing I receed I have been given
a written notice to my right to a
hearing including the steps required to
obtain a hearing and understand the
notice of suspension revocation or
denial license will be mailed to the
address of record on file the Department
of Licensing so I need your signature
there that you're getting this piece of
paper
this piece of paper is your criminal
citation so it has your information your
vehicle's information and what you're
being charged with driving Under the
Influence up top here essentially what
it says in the next 15 days they're
going to be mailing you in a packet of
this papers to this address you provided
me if that's wrong or you want your
paperwork to go somewhere else call the
court their website mail address all
right here the reason that's important
is if they assign you a court date and
you don't show up there' be a warrant
for your
rest this piece of paper is your copy of
the breath sample again just shows the
results of your two breath
samples that one
this pie paper is called your conditions
of release so when I release it here
this is what you have to follow so
anytime someone's arrested for DUI they
have to be in court the next court day
it's not your trial or anything but it's
an initial appearance they'll tell you
what you're being charged with they'll
give you information you have to be
there if you don't show up there's a
warrant for your rest so it's today the
15th at 1 I to be there today what
that's not I have class today no you
have court today what in what here so
listen today 1: p.m. fuck cfax
Washington that's fucking bullshit I
have class today and I have important
meetings today not bullshit you
committed a crime you need to be in
court are you going to show up for court
if you say no I book you into
jail yeah I'm going to go to court
excellent that's the right choice yeah
your appearance at the above time and
location is mandatory and it may not be
waved your failure to personally appear
for this hearing or failure to comply
with the blow conditions of release
shall result in the immediate issuance
of a bench warrant for your arrest so
when I let you go until you see the
judge this is what you have to do
depending this hearing the court has
ordered that you comply with the
following conditions of release one you
should not possess or consume alcohol or
unprescribed Controlled Substances two
you should not drive a motor vehicle
without a valid license with while
suspended or revoked and without
required liability insurance or
compliance with applicable
responsibility laws I promise to appear
I have received a copy of this notice
and I understand the above conditions of
release and I promise to comply and
appear as directed above
okay you understand where you have to be
and what
time if you don't then we'll just go to
your class or your house and arrest you
and then take you to
jail it would not be
awesome yeah I
know two signatures for
me first one's your fingerprint card
goes off to
FBI second one is a disposition sheets
used by the court to track the progress
of your case
right you can start putting your your
property back
on take your
[Applause]
blanket
for
can I leave or what yeah as soon as you
grab all your
stuff the door without the window there
push hard on that door push hard on the
second door you'll be out in the
lobby